就算他是真心的回来找你，
我告诉你，
真心的背后难道不是权衡利弊吗？
难道不是觉得你在的时候他日子过得好一点吗？
难道不是觉得你在的时候他的孩子日子过得好一点吗？
难道不是觉得你在的时候家庭关系相处起来要那个什么一点吗？
真心的背后难道不是这样的权衡利弊吗？
你谈什么真心？
所有的真心背后都是权衡利弊。
我36岁，
我老公是35岁，
我们结婚有12年，
有一个7岁的孩子，
当时呢，
我们结婚是比较着急的，
相亲大概一个月就结婚了，
婚后感情也还好，
但是也会经常吵闹，
生完孩子之后他就工作比较忙嘛，
对我就不太上心了。
20年我开始上班，
二一年我们买了房子，
二三年还完贷款，
等到二五年的时候又买了一辆车，
到25年的夏天的时候，
我发现了他手机有一张聊天截图，
非常路骨，
当时他只承认LS了，
他说对方可能就是能讲讲家里的琐碎的事情，
夫妻之间有些感情的问题，
但是他承认有些上头了，
我们两个就因为这件事情一直闹了几个月吧，
冷静证也也拿了两次，
到11月份的时候暂停了两个月，
就没有吵闹，
1月份的时候又因为一点小事情，
两个人就一直闹闹闹，
后来又去拿了一次冷静证，
他就搬出来了，
搬出来后呢，
中间他一直没有找过我，
但是我有找他的话，
他都会有回应，
后来我实在受不了了。
等到这个月的月初的时候，
我们就顺利拿证了，
拿证后面呢，
他就跟我说想要重新开始，
我就跟他讲的是，
我说两个人都这样子的话，
重新开始实可能不太能行吧，
当时说是这样说，
但是感情这个事情确实很难放下，
我现在呢，
问题就是我不知道他是不是真心的，
真心想重新开始，
我自己呢也确实放不下，
我想跟他说的是，
如果说嗯，
我们两个还想重新开始的话，
就有一些必须要做的条件，
他就跟我讲，
他说现在到这个时候了，
你还说什么条件不条件的，
就觉得我再拿他当工具，
然后呢就说冷静一下，
这个事情以后再说。
我就跟他讲的是，
如果说现在不能解决的话，
那我就可能要离开这个地方，
他就不让我走，
我现在就是卡在这个问题上了，
我那天听到一个观点啊，
我觉得这个观点很有用，
尤其是对我直播间的姐妹很有用，
也是一个小女孩儿才二十几岁，
她讲了一个观点，
他说我谈恋爱的时候，
我从来不在意他对我是不是真心的，
我只在意实实在在的，
我在这段关系当中有没有成长，
我在在这段关系当中有没有好处，
我在这段关系当中有没有进步，
我感觉啊，
这句话对于我来说，
对于一个我40多岁的人来说，
都有一种嗯，
很有道理的感觉，
就谈恋爱的时候真心这个东西，
我不管他真不真心，
他就算是虚伪的，
但他实实在在的能帮衬到我了，
他实实在在的在工作上给我。
或指点了，
实实在在在事业上给我帮忙了，
他真不真心的，
有什么要紧，
就现在我问你离开他了之后，
你日子过得好，
还是说他在的时候你日子过好，
你算一下，
日子嘛，
其实是差不多的，
但是我感情上应该是对他需求蛮高的，
我建议你不管将来你跟这个男的怎么样，
现在这个阶段你大胆去给我谈恋爱，
大胆的去，
不是大张旗鼓的去，
而是大胆的去给我谈恋爱，
你给我再谈两个，
如果你想回头的话，
你再回头你心里会平衡很多，
真的人就这么奇怪啊，
你再谈两个了之后，
你发现啊，
你们就那样了，
那你再回头就是都有可能从家里过来之后我们两个前几天吧又见了一次，
也说了很多，
他也说，
当时他也是有些冲动，
才跟我去拿了这个证，
他的意思就是我们两个人现阶段都不要去找，
冷静一段时间，
或者我搬回去带着孩子，
两个人先这样过，
我现在就是比较着急，
我喜欢把事情当下就解决，
不解决就是悬在这里，
我就想如果说不行的话，
那我就赶紧处离出来，
我换一个地方，
可能我对他感情上就没有这么依赖，
我跟你讲实话好不好？
这男的肯定是外面那个女的，
他处也处了，
觉得没有他想象中那么好，
或者说人家外面的女的没把她当回事儿，
或者说人家外面的女的提着要求，
她满足不了，
他现在才回来，
但凡我给他说，
你别扯别扯别扯，
但凡外面那个女的又漂亮又有钱，
对她又好，
他跟他在一起又。
开心又有希望，
事业上又能帮衬的他，
但凡那个女的那么好的话，
刚凡那个女的不甩他的话，
他不可能回头找你，
我告诉你，
去年夏天的时候，
当时发现当时把钱转了30块过来，
他当天也跟那个女的就删掉了，
后面我也有去求证，
确实是没有在一起，
两个人也确实没有联系了，
但是他就是觉得我一直很闹腾，
然后把他闹的他有点接受不了，
他崩溃，
我也觉得我总是放不下，
总是在纠结这件事情，
把很多小事情也都扯到了这件事情上面去，
你还找自己的原因了哈，
那你现在想问我，
我也找了自己的原因，
我想问的是他到底是不是有真心的想要重新开始这个问题，
妈呀，
这两还问我呀，
我哪知道他是不是真心啊，
那你就白瞎花这300块钱，
他是不是真心我哪知道？
我只知道啊，
人都是趋利避害的，
他回来找你，
证明在你这儿有利可图，
我这里的病不光是指的说啊，
你能带孩子啊，
你能给他一个社会身份啊，
你能给他一个家什么的，
不光是指这些，
包括sex，
包括各种，
他都是力，
他回来肯定是有利可图的。
我告诉你真心这个东西，
这谁能说的准？
他可能这一秒钟是真心，
他真心的背后难道没有算计吗？
真心的背后没有权衡利弊吗？
真心的背后没有周全的去考虑一下吗？
就算他是真心的回来找你，
我告诉你，
真心的背后难道不是权衡利弊吗？
难道不是觉得你在的时候他日子过得好一点吗？
难道不是觉得你在的时候他。
子日子过得好一点吗？
难道不是觉得你在的时候，
家庭关系相处起来要那个什么一点吗？
真心的背后难道不是这样的权衡利弊吗？
你谈什么真心？
所有的真心背后都是权衡利弊。
我想知道我现在要不要离开这个地方，
重新换一个地方，
在哪儿？
对于你来说，
日子过得好，
你就说在哪儿，
凭什么我们谈恋爱失败了，
结婚婚姻失败了，
跟一个男人的关系搞失败了，
我就要离开呢？
那我在哪里打江山，
哪里就是我的江山，
我在哪里日过得好，
我就在哪里，
我在哪里日子过得顺当，
哪里的地方问我，
我就在哪里，
我在哪里工作过，
挣钱多，
我就在哪里。
你要走，
你走，
我凭什么走？
以前演那个电视剧啊，
老公背叛了，
她跟别的女人好了，
这女的就说我要出国，
这女的就说我要离开这里，
这女的就说我什么都不要啊，
我就要离开，
好像你的离开对人家是一种惩罚似的，
屁都不是你的离开了之后，
你得重新打江山，
你得重新适应新的环境，
你得重新租房子，
你得重新买锅碗瓢盆儿，
多浪费钱，
我凭什么离开，
懂吗？
供你参考啊，
你一定要想想知我的日子，
自己想明白，
我的日子怎么过，
我舒心，
我高兴，
我的日子怎么过，
我手上的钱多，
我手上的资源多，
先想明白这个，
嗯，
好的好的，
就这啊，
好，
嗯，
来看下啊，
你们有没有印象，
就原来演那个电视剧，
老这样演，
哎呀，
男人背叛我了，
我好伤心，
我钱也不要。
什么都不要，
我拎着包我出国了，
让他难过去吧，
他难过个屁啊，
他分分钟找下家，
他分分钟找下一个。
我在哪里能挣钱我在哪里，
社会关系我比较喜欢我在哪里，
气候比较好我在里，
饮食我吃的顺口，
我在哪里，
我身体好我就在哪里。
记得点赞关注哦。